c'est une visuel déjà vous faire un
petit exercice de mémoire donc je montre
ça pour retenir bien c'est donc là quite
red green en haut à droite
ok alors je sais que gam gaf et ça a
bien retenu les quatre
bah oui tempête bien obtient 5 pouces et
messmer est un peu ça fait de vrai
mentaliste
maintenant on attend donc maintenant ce
que tu vas faire tu vas me répéter trois
fois de suite genre tatata la couleur en
bas à droite vas-y trois fois de suite
bringing à l'eau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez le lapin à la demande
elle maintenant c'est fini je suis là
[Rires]
dit il en a marre parce qu'il n'a pas de
il n'a pas de copine il a rien puis j'ai
dû au bordel top dès lors il rendit va
dans le couloir voisin y voilà quand
gozlin peut pas s'agir ave c trop grand
l'aïkido bâtirente et voit à le serpent
et puis ça s'est pas mal de temps de jeu
mais si ça pour rire on sépare le sapin
il fait ainsi super c'est super c'est le
déjeuner il prend la main il boucle la
part et la tenancière l'autruche city
mais pour que le lapin est toujours pas
senti un problème
elle va le bois avec la forme tu n'as
pas l'intérieur fait mais t'es malade ou
quoi
c'est un client spa la bouffe c'est un
client pour le bois comme ça elle le
fait tourner au bout d'un moment le
l'appareil s'écrase contre mûri ferrat
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est le petit singe à son papa l'a
alors vas-y l'arrivée au bar et
s'agrippe aux contrats conseil du garçon
vous avez des bananes et le garçon ait
dit non on n'a pas de man
même si ça j'ai dit vous avez du bénin
dit non je viens de vous dire je vais
pas de banal même 10 1 vous allez vous
n'allez nulle
je me demande encore une fois si j'ai du
mal à ce dialogue
jacou ce serait pour toi il s'agit dit
je vais des clous mais gilles auger pas
de clous alors jamais les valeurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]